salut je suis content une fois de plus
de vous retrouver j'espère que vous
allez bien
aujourd'hui je vous emmène avec moi
allons comparer retrouver jérémy laurier
un jeune martiniquais qui vit depuis
cinq ans
[Musique]
hamid jérémy notot moquent surtout pas
de mon accent anglais ah bah tu vois ça
c'est ça plus si et compagnie j'ai pas
été jusqu'à vendre encore assez vrai que
c'est un pays que j'ai pas j'ai pas eu
la chance de découvrir
pourtant je passais plusieurs fois à
côté toi tu y vit depuis à peu près cinq
ans et ça oui tout à fait et quasiment
s'est essentiellement fait je dirais
plus professionnels que j'ai eu ensuite
tu fais partie des français qui
travaillent à londres
tu bosses dans quoi exactement sur les
marchés des capitaux
d'accord ça consiste en quoi ça consiste
à lever de la dette des contreparties
qui ont des besoins de financement en
fait la dernière médiation d'accord bien
évidemment on a tous compris jérémy on
va laisser ça aux spécialistes
on a compris que travailler dans le
milieu de la finance des banques des
flux financiers et tout ça on sait que
londres d'ailleurs est une place
importante des marchés financiers avec
de grandes banques là bas et beaucoup
des changes
alors il ya le break site qui est arrivé
il ya quelques années on est en plein
dedans d'ailleurs avec très certainement
des changements il y avait beaucoup de
préoccupations de français qui
travaillait justement dans les milieux
financiers comme toi et qui se demandait
comment allait de demain est ce que vous
avez aujourd'hui et notamment toit plus
de visites
lité sur la peau cité de continuer à
travailler à l'ombre alors tout le monde
tout le monde un peu dans l'expectative
parce que c'est en fait un long chemin
en un peu dans le brouillard et je pense
que même les politiques qui sont en fait
de man est en train de négocier ne
savent pas vraiment sur quoi cela va
déboucher
l'idée pour les anglais c'est
effectivement de récupérer leur leur
souveraineté
voilà une nuit là il tente un petit peu
on va dire faire chemin de bargues du
regard des langues ne sache déjà
commencé à changer parce que beaucoup de
l'entreprise anticipé au bâtirons un
arbre excite et donc on fait pas mal de
leurs salariés revenus en europe
parce que voilà pour avoir la continuité
de l'entreprise
donc effectivement il ya déjà des flux
de salariés qui sont revenus entre
guillemets endroit pour l'instant
malheureusement on sait pas très bien et
les négociations sont en cours mais mais
effectivement présente à mon niveau j'ai
pas mal de collecte sont retournés à
paris d'autres francfort par exemple
soit exploité notre pourquoi avoir
choisi londres
mais l'on fait c'est avant tout
simplement une opportunité je n'avais
pas spécialement d'appeler là dessus et
est le premier jour de travail la base
de mon premier jour à londres
donc j'avais jamais mis les pieds je
passe je revenais de
on était plutôt sympa au soleil je suis
passé par paris les deux jours il
faisait encore beau il ya est en fête
bourgi dît l'eurostar terriblement j'ai
tout de suite été dans notre pape ce
qu'il pleuvait il faisait froid c'est
vrai que ça change des antilles en plus
londres est réputé pour avoir beaucoup
de jours pluvieux de brouillard c'est
pas la meilleure destination pour le
soleil en tout cas oui alors c'est vrai
parce que lorsqu'il pleut il pleut pas
jusqu'à paris la différence est
effectivement en tout cas tu rates et 32
degrés de température maximale qu'on en
ce moment aux antilles et le super ciel
bleu qu'on a des fils début du
confinement d'ailleurs un ciel bleu sans
nuage depuis quelques heures des
quelques semaines donc je sais pas si
c'est l'effet on va dire l'immédiat de
l'interaction humaine de l'activité
humaine sur l'environnement mais de
confinement on est content de voir en
tout cas que pour toi ça a l'air d'aller
écoute soit soit quand même prudent bien
évidemment histoire qu'on prévoit
bientôt en martinique
est-ce que c'est prévu d'ailleurs alors
j'aimerais bien y reviennent
effectivement ça serait donc venir cet
été s'il reste fiction sont confirmés a
priori elles le sont j'ai donc si les
réflexions sur le bs cas pas non plus
trop d'horreurs de ce qui est de 40 mg
bid et oui après on verra comment ça
évolue en série
[Musique]
tout peut très vite changer
bonjour amis comme on est à la télé il
ya plein de gens qui regardent en plus
en ce moment si tu as de la famille ou
des amis qui tu veux passer un petit
coucou c'est le moment et lui fait
qu'ils sont qui sont sur place et je
droit qui merci beaucoup jérémy bats toi
aussi tu prends soin de toi et puis
bravo pour ton parcours dans la finance
et continue sur sa bonne lancée merci en
tout cas et à très bientôt
merci à toi à très bientôt voilà c'était
le parcours de jérémy laurier
martiniquais qui nous prouve une fois de
plus qu'on peut briller ou qu'on se
trouve dans le monde
à condition bien évidemment de s'en
donner les moyens c'est des cons finis
d'ici et d'ailleurs on se retrouve très
vite sur la première à très bientôt
[Musique]